Nintendo switch is getting the
definitive version of rayman legends
which means it's coming with a few
surprises I'm Tony this is a GameSpot
news update and for all the latest on
Ubisoft games on switch be sure to hit
that subscribe button the definitive
edition includes a new come foot mode
and more unannounced bonuses Rayman
creator michelle on-cell appeared in a
Nintendo video to talk about the game
and why it's a good fit for the new
console
he said Rayman legends is like a board
game it means playing with your friends
in the same room and this console is
perfect for that it's the concept of
console we've been waiting for a long
time an HD console powerful portable
rayman legends' is one of three Ubisoft
games confirmed for the console
alongside Just Dance 2017 and steep for
more Nintendo switch coverage check out
our discussion on how the new console
will affect the 3ds that's on the lobby
GameSpot's live show every Wednesday at
11:00 a.m. Pacific and for all the
latest on the switches upcoming games
you're already in the right place